hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live mit einem will sich heute in
Brüssel jeder und jeder fotografieren
lassen Präsident selenski ist zum
EU-Gipfel gekommen nicht wie sonst im
letzten Jahr virtuell sondern ganz real
ist er da für die EU-Partner ist heute
deshalb vor allem auch eins wichtig
große Bilder zeigen dass man an der
Seite der Ukraine steht ob
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen oder Ratspräsident Charlie
Michelle sie alle wollen zeigen wir sind
deine Partner in Europa auch der
französische Präsident macron bei dem
selenski gestern zu Gast war die Bilder
sind wichtig auch Scholz war mit dabei
denn in der EU in den letzten Wochen gab
es Uneinigkeit Uneinigkeit ob überhaupt
wer wie viele Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine
liefert und nun steht auch schon die
nächste Forderung im Raum selensky
die Ukraine braucht jetzt folgendes
Artilleriegeschütze Munition moderne
Panzer
Langstreckenraketen und moderne
Kampfflugzeuge hier
wie realistisch diese Forderung ist und
was aus den Versprechungen in Sachen
Kampfpanzern aus Europa für die Ukraine
geworden ist dass es heute unser Thema
wer hilft wirklich und ihr könnt Fragen
stellen im Stream direkt oder per Mail
und mit kommentieren denn wir können
sprechen und analysieren und jetzt
zuerst mit unserem Korrespondenten in
Brüssel live vor Ort mit Ulf Röhler der
jetzt bei uns ist hallo Ulf hallo hallo
freut mich Ulf Bilder Worte der
Solidarität diese großen Bilder das
wollen die Partner heute natürlich vor
allem auch zeigen was ist denn deine
Einschätzung ist denn auch mehr als nur
große Bilder bislang dabei herumgekommen
also ich glaube dass der lynski einen
Plan gehabt hat und er weiß dass seine
schärfste Waffe in diesem Diskussionen
hier in Europa ist um die Skeptiker für
weitere Waffenlieferung zu überzeugen da
ist eben seine schärfste Waffe Bilder
und große Gesten große Worte die hat er
sehr massiv eingesetzt um auch alle
unter Druck zu setzen er hat sehr
deutlich gemacht wie dringend die
Ukraine Hilfe braucht und er hat
eigentlich auch zwischen den Zeilen sehr
deutlich gemacht dass eine Debatte wie
die panzerdebatte die aus seiner Sicht
viel zu lange gedauert hat und auch zu
lange dauert bis die Panzer kommen dass
das ein Problem ist wir müssen es gibt
Hinweise dass die russische Offensive
vielleicht schon begonnen hat oder
gerade davor ist zu starten und deshalb
ist es ein riesen Problem weil die
Panzer die man der Ukraine versprochen
hat werden einfach nicht da sein
rechtzeitig die kommen im Sommer
insofern ist das ein riesen Problem und
er hat dies deutlich gemacht um eben
Druck auszuüben bei der großen Frage
Kampf Gesetz zumindestens hat er so ein
bisschen den Eindruck erweckt dass er
positives Signale bekommen hat ich bin
mir da ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz sicher
ich glaube man wollte heute die
Emotionen die großen Bilder nicht stören
aber es gibt doch noch sehr sehr viel
Skepsis bei den einzelnen EU-Regierungen
dass man eben Kampfjets für eine weitere
Eskalation hält die man momentan nicht
will
Botschaft in Brüssel die war ganz
deutlich bei einer Niederlage gegen
Russland ist es nicht nur die Ukraine
die vernichtet würde deshalb sprechen
wir jetzt auch mit unserer Reporterin in
der Ukraine mit Katrin Eigendorf die
jetzt auch bei uns ist hallo Katrin
hallo Katrin deine Einschätzung
selenskys Besuch heute in Brüssel wie
wird das in der Ukraine gesehen ist das
jetzt schon ein Erfolg der da gesehen
wird es könnten vielleicht jetzt mehr
Waffenlieferungen kommen Wunder als
Hoffnung geweckt in der Ukraine neue
Hoffnung
also die Hoffnungen der Ukrainer sind in
letzter Zeit deutlich getrübt worden
weil man sieht natürlich mittlerweile
schon es gibt immer viele treffen und
jeder möchte sich gerne mit dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten an seiner Seite
auf Fotos ablichten lassen man feiert
ihn so als eine Art Superhelden der
Demokratie und der Freiheit
aber letztendlich stellen sich die
Ukraine hier natürlich die Frage was
kommt konkret bei solchen Treffen raus
und das ist doch relativ dünn aus ihrer
Sicht ähm man muss sich das so
vorstellen sie lensky unternimmt diese
Reise nach Europa in einem Moment wo er
als Präsident aber auch das Land
wirklich mit dem Rücken an der Wand
steht wir haben auf der einen Seite ist
hier mit einer militärischen Situation
zu tun wo man sagen kann dass diese
Offensive aus meiner Perspektive
eigentlich längst begonnen hat ist
natürlich immer schwer da eine Linie zu
ziehen aber Russland hat seine Angriffe
auf die Ukraine massiv ausgeweitet
greift inzwischen auch wieder Städte
große Städte wie hartjew verstärkt an
wir haben eine Situation in bachmut wo
man wirklich sagen kann die Stadt ist
kurz davor preisgegeben werden zu müssen
weil die Russen einfach dort in mit so
brutaler in so brutaler Form agieren
dass sich diese Stadt wahrscheinlich
nicht auf Dauer halten lassen wird außer
die Ukraine würde einen menschlichen
Preis zahlen der der sehr sehr sehr weit
geht und das große Problem ist eben dass
alle Waffenlieferungen über die wir ja
sehr hier seit Monaten bereits
debattieren viel zu spät kommen also das
ist die Situation auf der militärischen
Seite aber wir haben es natürlich auch
humanitär mit einer mit einer Situation
zu tun wo dieses Land immer weiter in
die Katastrophe Gerät in die gezielte
gezielten Angriffe Russlands auf
Infrastruktur auf Zivilisten die zeigen
mittlerweile ihren Preis denn es ist ja
eiskalt es ist Winter hier tief geht es
noch im Osten der Ukraine ist es noch
mal deutlich kälter viele Leute haben
keinen Strom haben keine Heizung
teilweise sind Gebäude soweit zerstört
dass man da kaum noch drin leben kann
und es ist in manchen Städten eben auch
die Frage wie will man die Menschen dort
dauerhaft versorgen
richtige Frage die uns Kathrin Eigendorf
jetzt noch mitgibt vielen Dank für die
Einschätzung live aus der Ukraine Ulf
bleibt noch einen Moment bei uns es gibt
noch mehr worüber wir heute sprechen
wollen und wir schauen aber erstmal
genauer auf die leopardlieferungen
schauen uns gleich gemeinsam einen
Beitrag an denn lange wurde ja über die
Leopard 2 Lieferung zwischen den
westlichen Partnern diskutiert
Deutschland als Verhinderer gesehen
andere viel früher versprochen dass sie
liefern wollen was genau ist diesen
Versprechungen jetzt aber geworden ist
schauen wir rein einen Beitrag von
Thomas gonzia
der Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 feuerstark und
modern international war der Druck auf
Deutschland groß möglichst viele zur
Verfügung zu stellen und deren Ausfuhr
zu genehmigen dann die Zusage der
Bundesregierung 14 werden geliefert
ebenso viele sagt Polen zu Kanada 4
macht 32 versprochen waren zwei
Bataillone das entspricht in der Ukraine
62 Panzern mindestens es fehlen noch 30
Ernüchterung bei Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius im ZDF heute journal es
bestehe nach wie vor die Hoffnung dass
wir ein bis zwei Bataillone zusammen
bekommen aber das hängt jetzt im
Augenblick nicht mehr von Deutschland ab
sondern von den anderen Partnern die
sich ja vor der Konferenz in Ramstein
auch entsprechend geäußert haben helfen
zu wollen und das müssen wir jetzt
zusammentragen
Leopard 2 zu liefern dafür machten
Spanien und Portugal zusagen aber wie
viele sie exportieren das ließen sie
offen die Niederlande sprachen von 18
Leopard 2 Panzern ohne feste Zusagen nur
wenige Länder haben sich auch in Sachen
Leopard 1 zusammengetan Deutschland will
zusammen mit Dänemark den Niederlanden
und Belgien insgesamt 100 liefern 20 bis
Mitte des Jahres
unabhängig von der EU haben die USA 31
Kampfpanzer vom Typ Abrams zugesagt und
Großbritannien 14 Challenger 2
militärisch sonst auf Augenhöhe sieht
sich Frankreich doch das EU-Land hat
sich bisher nicht entschieden ob es
einen kampfpanzerle klärt zur Verfügung
stellt es gebe gar nicht genug so
Experten und französische Politiker
behaupten die Ukraine wolle den lecler
gar nicht
den gegenüber steht dieses Video der
Leclerc dazu Chanson Musik
ins Netz gestellt vom ukrainischen
Verteidigungsministerium Botschaft die
Ukraine braucht Panzer auch aus
Frankreich
und Deutschland ruft eben weitere
europäische Länder zu Lieferung auf am
Dienstag trifft sich dazu die Ukraine
Kontaktgruppe und Präsident macron wir
haben es an in den Bildern am Anfang
schon gesehen kam er gestern schon zu
Gesprächen zusammen mit selensky und
Scholz gemeinsam in Frankreich da war
viel Inszenierung dabei selensky der
zuerst von macron begrüßt wurde Scholz
der erst wesentlich später dann dazu kam
und wir haben im Beitrag auch eben
gerade gehört in Frankreich behaupten
sie die Ukraine die Wünsche den
Kampfpanzer Leclerc gar nicht Wolf wie
verlässlich ist denn macron mit seinen
Versprechungen also werden die
tatsächlich dann jetzt aber auch
eingelöst
also man müsste erstmal genau wissen was
denn der französische Präsident
versprochen hat weil man hat doch den
Eindruck dass das nicht so klar ist
gerade der französische Präsident macron
ist jemand der sehr gerne die große
Geste liebt und man hat gesehen er ist
mit selenski seit an seit in Paris
gestartet und gelaufen er ist ja auch
mit ihm hierher gekommen nach Brüssel
hat in die mitgenommen im Flugzeug und
macht die große Geste die deutschen
Delegation ist ein bisschen sage ich mal
irritiert weil sie sagt natürlich die
Franzosen sind stark in der Geste aber
sie liefern nicht wie gesagt den Panzer
nicht auch bei Kampfjets lässt man den
Eindruck so ein bisschen offen von
Französisch Seite als sei man bereit
aber intern heißt es und die Franzosen
das auch nicht und so sagen die
Deutschen eigentlich es ist schon
erstaunlich wäre wirkten isoliert Olaf
Scholz wirkte isoliert am Anfang und
alle haben so getan als wenn die
Deutschen bei den Panzern blockieren und
nun sieht man dass die Deutschen doch
relativ groß nach den Amerikanern und
mit den jemand zusammen die großen
Waffenlieferanten sind und die anderen
sich ein bisschen verstecken und jetzt
mit den Panzern nicht kommen und wenn
sie kommen dann kommen sie auch noch
viel zu spät wir haben das gerade von
Katrin Eigendorf gehört die Offensive
ist wohl schon im Gange die werden die
deutschen denn jetzt gesehen was
bekommst du mit jetzt gerade bei dem
Gipfel in Brüssel denn sie immerhin also
Deutschland hat der Ukraine ja
Militärhilfen von bisher rund 3,3
Milliarden Euro zugesagt da sind die
leopardlieferungen ja noch nicht mal
eingerechnet wird da Deutschland jetzt
aktuell immer noch als Zögerer
Blockierer gesehen
also es gibt ja dieses eine Interview
das selensky jetzt quasi parallel zu dem
Gipfel mit dem Spiegel geführt hat und
doch da sehr kritisch sich über
Bundeskanzler Scholz am geäußert hat ich
glaube das liegt nicht so sehr
vielleicht daran was am Ende geliefert
wird weil wie gesagt die deutschen da
ein sehr großer Waffenlieferant sind
sondern es ist ein Grund dass doch
gerade selensky und auch viele
Osteuropäer also die beiden ein bisschen
das Gefühl haben dass immer noch die
deutschen zurückhaltend sind was die
Frage angeht ob die Ukraine diesen Krieg
eben gewinnen soll das sagt ja auch Olaf
Scholz nicht im Gegensatz zu macron der
das immer wiederholt und viele sagen ist
halt doch sehr vorsichtig weil eben Olaf
Scholz fürchtet wenn man der Ukraine zu
viele versprechen macht eben auch zu
große Waffen gibt wie Kampfjets dann
beschlittert man langsam in ein Konflikt
mit Russland rein und das will Olaf
Scholz unbedingt verhindern also es
immer wieder einer der auch sehr stark
auf die Gefahr der Eskalation betont und
er tut das auch auf solchen Gipfeln auch
wenn die großen Bilder dann diese
Harmonie ausdrücken ist durchaus Olaf
Scholz ich will nicht sagen ein
Spielverderber aber man hört immer
wieder dass er sagt wir müssen auch
vorsichtig sein dass wir eben wie gesagt
nicht in eine Eskalation mit Russland
reinrutschen es gibt einige Fragen bei
uns im Stream zu den anderen Ländern die
ja große Versprechungen gemacht haben
ich greife eine Frage raus von Chuck
norr bei Youtube er oder sie fragt es
gab doch die große Koalition die Druck
auf Deutschland ausgeübt hat und sauer
auf Scholz war weil er so zögerlich war
wieso liefern die jetzt alle nicht
ich muss das bisschen vorsichtig sein
weil ich bin kein Militärexperte aber
was ich verstanden habe ist so dass die
die Spanier die liefern wollten wohl
jetzt diese Leopard 2 Panzer Reparatur
bedürftig sind und dass das eine ganze
Weile dauert die instand zu setzen also
da hat man wohl den Eindruck erweckt
dass man bessere oder fittere Panzer hat
als das wirklich der Fall ist die Finnen
haben gar nicht so viele die norwegisch
die die Niederländer würden vielleicht
gerne 18 Panzer liefern die haben die
aber von Deutschland geleast und nun
gibt es da Diskussion ob man die
freigeben kann oder nicht und wie gesagt
frankreich hat zwar immer den Eindruck
erweckt sehr stark dabei zu sein aber
wenn es um die Lieferung das sind dann
eine klare heißen glaube ich die Panzer
die Kampfpanzer der Franzosen kommt ist
bisher nichts nichts passiert also die
deutsche Regierung würde sagen also wir
sind da ein bisschen zu Unrecht
verdächtigt worden dass wir isoliert
sind und allein sind sondern viele haben
sich hinter dem doch großen Deutschland
versteckt und wo jetzt Deutschland
vorangegangen ist mit Amerika und den
Engländern sieht man dass es eben für
viele andere Länder nicht so einfach ist
weil es an die Substanz geht in den
Armeen und das dann der Wille vielleicht
doch nicht so groß ist wie am Anfang der
Eindruck erweckt wurde ein Schätzungen
live aus Brüssel von unserem
Korrespondenten ulferrella zum EU-Gipfel
gemeinsam mit Präsident selenski vielen
Dank
gerne
sehr gerne wollte ich noch sagen und er
hat vor allem ultra angesprochen er sei
kein Militärexperte aber Gott sei Dank
den haben wir jetzt eingeladen hier bei
uns in der Sendung und ihr könnt jetzt
noch mehr Fragen stellen denn bei uns
ist Gustav gressel netterweise wieder
einmal Militärexperte vom European
Council und vorhin relations schön dass
Sie bei uns sind hallo
darüber was die Kampfpanzer wenn sie
denn dann irgendwann kommen bewirken
können darauf wollen wir jetzt noch mal
auch genauer eingehen die mir vielleicht
zunächst mal aber ganz konkret auf die
zugesagten Leopard Kampfpanzer ein da
wurden wie wir auch schon gelernt haben
auch im Beitrag eben noch nicht alle
konkreten Zusagen gemacht warum sind
denn da vielleicht jetzt die anderen
EU-Länder dann doch wieder zögerlich
geworden oder waren Sie vielleicht schon
immer
nein also bei wir haben sozusagen zwei
Kategorien von Leopard frei das eine
sind die die aus den bestehenden
Streitkräften kommen also die schon
sozusagen im Truppeneinsatz sind da
müssen die Staaten umschichten schauen
wie sie welchen Kräften was wegnehmen
das ist meistens das schmerzlichste wenn
keine Mine Europa betreibt Kampfpanzer
zum Spaß und sozusagen man hat ja auch
selber Verteidigung Verpflichtungen
diese Panzer werden aber sofort
verfügbar weil er funktionieren weil die
ja in den Streitkräften eingesetzt sind
und in tadellosen Zustand sind und dann
gibt's die zweite Kategorie das sind
reservegerät also Geräte die in Depot
stehen Geräte die man sich vorgenommen
hat dass man mal modernisiert
die kann man natürlich leichter abgeben
politisch weil man den eigenen
Streitkräften nicht weh tut aber die
müssen alle repariert werden
und
beim zweiten gibt es mehr davon oder
sagen wir so kann man mehr raus kriegen
wir haben die die spanische Depot schon
angesprochen auch in deutschen Industrie
Beständen gibt es noch welche da
sozusagen ist auch Reparaturbedarf da
die kommen aber alle später
zu dem bestehenden ja Polen liefert auch
noch 14 zu A4 das soll jetzt dieses Tor
4 Bataillon aufstellen bei der 2004 bei
der älteren Variante wie gesagt da
gibt's mehr die kommen aber alle und die
meisten davon kommen eben später weil
sie repariert werden müssen zur
Koalition von 2006 das ist das oder
Deutschland jetzt führend ist
wo
die 14 Panzer der Bundeswehr hin sollen
da ist die mengenlage natürlich ein
bisschen schwieriger weil es dabei
weniger davon gibt und wir haben es ja
gerade mit den Niederlanden gehört da
gibt es jetzt anscheinend ein bisschen
sowas weil diese zwei sechs sieben von
Deutschland genießt sind und
hier anscheinend noch nicht ganz
Einigkeit mit mit dem zwischen den
beiden Verteidigungsministerien geht wie
man diese diese 18 Stück jetzt ausweisen
Beständen bzw auch aus diesem Leasing
contingent rauslöst und gibt und sonst
ist das Problem dass bei der moderneren
Leopard 2 Varianten auch die
Länderversionen jeweils immer
unterschiedlich sind weil da sozusagen
andere Systeme zum Teil andere
Panzerschutz verbastelt wurde und
deshalb ist relativ schwierig ist dann
harmonisches Paket zu schnüren
aber im Grunde
also ich sozusagen Teile dem Pessimismus
jetzt nicht nicht so ganz der sich in
Deutschland ein bisschen breit macht
es wird bei einigen Ländern noch ein
bisschen dauern weil es jetzt auch
Managementaufgabe ist also politisch ist
es geklärt die Kampfpanzer kommen aber
die Managementaufgabe wie man es
organisiert wie man Fahrzeuge instand
setzt wie man ablösen organisiert
hier stehen der Schweizer Kampfpanzer im
Raum die innerhalb der EU exportiert
werden können all das ist machbar aber
es ist halt eine Aufgabe die die jetzt
durchgeplant werden muss und das dauert
leider ein bisschen Zeit vielleicht für
alle die sich jetzt nicht so gut
auskennen sie haben jetzt eben gerade
den Leopard 2 A6 erwähnt vielleicht dass
wir uns noch mal kurz erklären was es
vielleicht von dem jetzt einen Vorteil
gegenüber anderen Panzertypen
Sex ist ein modernere Version also eine
neuere Version er hat eine
leistungsfähigere Kanone mit dem
längeren Rohr er hat eine stärkere
Panzerung er hat auch bessere und
modernere wärmebildgeräte
verbaut und ein Feuerleitrechner das
Problem ist auch deutlich schwerer als
ein
älterer Vorgänger das heißt für zum
Beispiel für Bergegerät oder für
brückengerät auch eine größere Belastung
aber er ist natürlich auch deutlich
leistungsfähiger
es gibt Fragen bei uns im Stream an sie
und wenn wir jetzt gerade über die
Panzertypen sprechen vielleicht bleiben
wir auch kurz beim Thema Berlin hatte
auch die Lieferung von Leopard 1
genehmigt Leopard 1 Panzern da scheinen
mehr Länder konkret auch schon darauf zu
reagieren andere Partnerländer da gibt's
die Frage von Sigma bei uns bei Youtube
er oder sie möchte wissen viele Länder
liefern dazu viel zu alte Panzer die
nicht wirklich nützlich sind sprechen
wir mal über den Leopard 1 im Vergleich
zum Leopard 2 wäre das jetzt ein so ein
viel zu alter Panzer wäre der wirklich
dann nicht nützlich
natürlich deutlich älter und weniger
Leistungsfähigkeit aber er hat natürlich
auch seinen seinen Nutzen wenn man
sozusagen ein Grund warum jetzt viel
Leopard 1 geliefert wird weil er
natürlich niemanden weh tut diese Panzer
sind ausgeschieden in den meisten EU und
NATO-Staaten deshalb muss man die keiner
Streitmacht wegnehmen aber auch die
müssen modernisiert werden also den
beziehungsweise wieder entstand gesetzt
werden auch denen steht sozusagen liegt
das rumstehen nicht
der Leopard eins ist natürlich kein
Kampfpanzer den Kampfpanzer Duell gegen
einen T90 oder einen eine moderne
Rezession 70 Variante viel Chancen hatte
seine seine Kanone ist deutlich weniger
leistungsstark als die das Leopard 2
werden geringeren Durchschlag in der
Ukraine kommen aber direkte panzerteile
relativ selten vor
und die Ukraine braucht Kampfpanzer
gebraucht die Kampfpanzer auch in den
meisten Fällen so direkt in Vertrieb
Unterstützung und zu Feuerunterstützung
da tut der Leopard 1 genauso wie wie
jeder andere
auch
als Reserve an weniger aktiven
Frontabschnitten etwa gegenüber
transnistrieren gegenüber Belarus wo der
Leopard 1 in erster Linie ist Jagdpanzer
verwendet werden würde also sollte von
dort jemand über die Grenze gehen aus
fest ausgebauten Stellungen mit der
Hauptwaffe wirken muss auch nur wenige
Straßen zum Beispiel von Belarus runter
in Ukraine gibt's nur sehr wenige
Straßen ausgedehnte Waldgebiete und den
Gegner gut kanalisieren kann und ich
hier sozusagen gepanzerte Reserven die
Binden zurzeit moderne Kampfpanzer die
dort in Reserven behalten werden die
könnte man dann wieder in den Dom was
schicken
also ukrainische die 64 ukrainische
Zitron 72
da hat er schon auch seine Verwendung
aber auch wie gesagt diesen Kampfpanzer
Typ hat es rumstehen auch nicht gut
getan auch die werden erst in der
zweiten Jahreshälfte kommen es gibt auch
sorgenvolle Stimme bei uns im Stream ich
möchte ein paar Vorlesen zum einen
schreibt hier
ambxyz wenn man selenskys Forderungen
immer wieder nachgibt wird die Lage
immer mehr eskalieren und das Bo 27
schreibt ich frage mich wann die ersten
truppenförderungen kommen dann schließt
sich dann auch die Frage von Jumpy wie
der oder die Userin sich nennt wie sieht
es mit menschlichen Reserven der Ukraine
aus die wären jetzt am Limit oder müssen
dran was machen die Verbündeten dagegen
wenn man nicht Kriegspartei werden
möchte
ja also die Forderung nach Gruppen
dieser schon lange vom Tisch das weiter
am Anfang des Krieges diese Forderung
nach einer Flugverbotszone das wären
dann eben nato-piloten in der Ukraine
gewesen das ist vom Tisch das diskutiert
auch niemand mehr und das auch völlig
ausgeschlossen
nach den mehr Forderungen also es stellt
sich für die Ukraine das Problem dass
sie mit einer Armee in diesen Krieg
gezogen ist die hauptsächlich Geräte
östlichen Typs verwendet sowohl
Flugzeuge Kampfbahn zu Schützenpanzer
bis runter zu gelassen und das für viele
dieser Geräte Munition und Ersatzteile
entweder nur mehr in Russland
hergestellt werden
nicht mehr in Osteuropa vorhanden sind
oder nur mehr knapp vorhanden sind wie
die Lieferketten nicht kontrollieren und
die Munition und Ersatzteile die wir
noch hatten
mittlerweile zu Neige geht und und
verschossen wird das war ja auch das
sozusagen ein einer der Grund der
Kampfpanzer Anstrengungen ist es nicht
so sehr dass sozusagen ein Telefon 160
oder eine 70 oder ein Beute der T-80 ein
schlechter Kampfpanzer wäre oder gegen
vor allen Dingen gegenüber einem älteren
Leopard 2,4 jetzt in der Kapazität zu
viel geringer ist das Problem dieser
Panzer ist beim z.B beim Beute T-80 dass
er mit einer Gasturbine Fahrt die
Ukraine für die ist in der Ersatzteile
gibt die hier nicht hergestellt werden
und beim bei all diesen Panzern das eben
für das sowjetische Klima 125 mm äh es
schwierig ist gewisse Klassen von
Munition überhaupt zu bekommen und bei
bei der gesamten Munition sie in der
nötigen Quantität zu bekommen bei
Munition die wir selber in größeren
Mengen herstellen die entspricht dem
natus Standard die passt aber nicht in
russischen Panzer aber ehrlich ist
natürlich auch bei Flugzeugen die
ukrainische Luftwaffe ist relativ aktiv
überhaupt Aufgabengebiet über diesen
ganzen Winter war eben die Bekämpfung
von Drohnen
im zwischengelände wo es keine Flieger
Einstellungen gibt da hat man schon
relativ viele längfluhkörper verschossen
also Luft Luft Raketen die eben dann
Drohnen die dann eben diese
Marschflugkörper abschießen können
da wurde vor allen Dingen aus Polen aber
auch von anderen osteuropäischen Staaten
geliefert man hat ja mit 29 extra
stillgelegt auch um hier Ersatzteile
frei zu machen und Bewaffnung frei zu
machen aber auch das dadurch dass sie in
diesem Winter sehr stark Bean
beansprucht wurden hat irgendwie sein
Ende jetzt kann man für gewisse
lenkflowkörper die auch sozusagen auch
westliche Bauer dann westlichen
Maschinen anbringen wenn man ein
bisschen bastelt und modifiziert
sie lassen sich aber nicht sehr gut also
zur vollen Kapazität einsetzen und es
kostet einigen Geldaufwand und Mühe und
was man sich dann genauso über den
Kampfpanzern irgendwann fragen muss
ist es nicht einfach gescheiter
gebrauchte F16 zu liefern dann kann man
gewisse munitionsklassen relativ
umfänglich und ohne Probleme dort
einsetzen und es macht die Logistik
eigentlich einfacher und warum machen
wir es uns extra kompliziert
in erster Linie einen USA hängen in
dieser Frage da da haben die Europäer
nicht nicht besonders viel zu geben
gehen wir einen Schritt weiter eben von
den Kampfpanzern zu dem was heute auch
noch im Raum stand was wir auch am
Anfang der Sendung gehört haben was er
denn auch gefordert hat nämlich die
Flugzeuge da passt von Eckhard Schneider
der Kommentar bei Facebook er schrieb
selensky kann den Krieg alleine nicht
gewinnen deshalb versucht er die
nato-schritt für Schritt in den Krieg
mit Russland hineinzuziehen so die
Meinung hier von Eckert Schneider mit
der Lieferung von Kampfflugzeugen würden
aus Unterstützern Kriegsteilnehmern
findet er
Stichwort Flugzeuge selensky hatte auch
eben einen Tag vor dem EU-Gipfel
Großbritannien besucht die Briten
zeigten sich grundsätzlich nicht
abgeneigt am Flugzeuge eben zu liefern
wie realistisch ist das ihrer Meinung
nach dass das wirklich dazu kommt
also es ist relativ realistisch ich
schätze das ist eine eine Kampfflugzeug
Entscheidung in den nächsten Monaten
fallen wird ich glaube zwar nicht dass
es ein britisches Kampfflugzeug wird
weil die Briten also vor einigen
Eurofighter jetzt betreiben sehr
erwartungsintensives Flugzeug
ich tippe auf einstrahliges flugzeug
oder ein Flugzeug das für die für den
Betrieb von Flugzeugträgern aus
zugelassen ist
weil diese Geräte nicht mehr auf
minimalen Wartungsaufwand getrennt sind
auf einem Flugzeugträger habe ich ja
nicht viel Platz und nicht viel
Möglichkeiten Flugzeuge groß zu warten
und auch sehr steile landewinkel
hinnehmen können deshalb kann ich sie
auch von kurzen Strecken von
autobahnpisten von von von größeren
Bundesstraßen ausstaaten und diese
Geräte werden werden es wahrscheinlich
werden das macht niemanden zu kriegst
oder Teil genauso wie die Kampfpanzer
niemanden zu Kriegspartei machen genauso
wie die Artillerie niemanden zur
Kriegspartei macht die Sowjetunion hatte
an
an nicht nur Vietnam und Korea
Kampfflugzeuge geliefert auch an Ägypten
an Syrien während der nordkriegen die
Sowjetunion hat oft auch Kampfflugzeuge
mit Piloten geliefert die dann dort auch
in den Krieg eintreten
und das hat die Sowjetunion damals auch
nicht zu direkt zur Kriegspartei gemacht
also dieses ganze wir werden dann
Kriegspartei das ist völlig leere
Propaganda die Moskau verbreitet und die
hier von den sozusagen Moskau höheren
Parteien einfach wiederholt wird aber da
ist nichts dahinter Kriegsparteien
würden wir werden wenn wir eine NATO
Division in die Ukraine schicken und das
tut keiner haben das wissen auch die
Ukrainer ganz genau dass das nicht
kommen wird egal was in der Ukraine
passiert
na unsere User haben schon teilweise
auch andere Meinungen Userin Dagmar
schreibt ohne Waffen kann man Frieden
schaffen nur Sieg ohne Krieg also so
ganz grundsätzlich schreibt sie das aber
bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei dem Thema
mit den Kampfflugzeugen Deutschland hat
nein gesagt auch schon im Vorfeld das
eigentlich ausgeschlossen jetzt haben
wir ja gesehen aber in den letzten
Wochen Monaten immer wieder wurden ja
auch von deutscher Seite rote Linien da
verschoben glauben sie ist bleibt bei
dem deutschen Nein zu den Flugzeugen
ich glaube es wird bei dem deutschen
nein bleiben wobei es ist ja es gibt
keine kollektive nato-position zu
Waffenlieferungen sonst hätte er Viktor
Orban sein veter recht schon längst
gebraucht gemacht
es ist eine immer eine individuelle
Entscheidung der Mitgliedstaaten Waffen
oder Munition zu senden oder nicht beim
Leopard braucht es halt ein eine
deutsche Entscheidung bei der Leopard
ein deutscher Kampfpanzer ist in
Deutschland hergestellt bzw auch wenn er
in den letzten Lizenz produziert wurde
deutsches geistiges Eigentum deshalb
muss das Endnutzer Zertifikat für diesen
Kampfpanzer immer aus Berlin auch wenn
es verändert wird ein okay dazu geben
das kann man ohne deutschen Konsens
einfach nicht in Ukraine liefern deshalb
sozusagen der der große Druck der auf
Deutschland aufgebaut wurde und deshalb
stand Berlin im Zentrum des ganzen
Geschehens bei Kampfflugzeugen steht
Berlin nicht im Zentrum des Geschehens
da gibt's ja sozusagen manche Fantasten
die meinen der Tornado könnte in die
Ukraine gehen wer auch ein extrem teures
Flugzeug mit mit relativ beschränkten
Kapazitäten vor allen Dingen was Luft
Lufteinsatz angeht also da wäre der
Aufwand sozusagen das Resultat nicht
wert Deutschland baut sehr gute
Kampfpanzer Deutschland baut sehr gute
Schützenpanzer hier kann es wirklich
einen Unterschied machen und einen
Beitrag leisten aber man muss nicht
krampfhaft irgendwas liefern um
irgendwas zu liefern wenn es wenn
sozusagen der Aufwand für den Nutzen
nicht steht wie gesagt die die
Kampfflugzeug Debatte wird sich und
unter sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit um
amerikanische Muster drehen es wird sich
um starten drehen die Flugzeuge haben
die wie gesagt von Flugzeugträgern aus
einsetzbar sind weil die für einen
grauen Betrieb von improvisierten
Flugpisten besser geeignet sind damit
gibt es ein gewisses Schielen auf
Frankreich damit gibt es vor allen
Dingen in vielen Richtung USA und und
anderer maritimer starten
und da da wird einfach in Berlin wenig
zu entscheiden sein schauen wir noch mal
auf die Lage ganz aktuell in der Ukraine
wir haben es von unserer Reporterin
Katrin eikendorf gehört sie sagte
eigentlich hätte die Frühjahrsoffensive
die russische die man befürchtet hat
eigentlich schon begonnen wie ist denn
gerade die Lage an der Front wie kann
man das im Moment einschätzen wir haben
in unseren Agenturen wenig Bilder in den
letzten Tagen von der Front gesehen was
wissen sie
nicht gut aus also
in allen Frontabschnitten im Grunde
drücken die Russen sehr stark an
bachmut haben wir vor dem Beitrag schon
gesehen da ist die Lage
wirklich nicht schön die russischen
Kräfte im Süden haben sie Geländegewinne
gemacht auch auch im Norden das heißt
die Stadt wird bald aufgegeben werden
müssen
wir haben auch einen anderen Freund
Abschnitten sehr starke
angriffstätigkeiten die werden
zurückgeschlagen und untere Renten
russischen Verlusten und ich schätze das
ist sozusagen
diese angriffstätigkeiten einfach
einfach jetzt stückweise steigern werden
also diese
Frühjahrsoffensive die ist jetzt im Gang
die wird wahrscheinlich noch stärker
über die nächsten Wochen und Monate weil
einfach schrittweise mobil gemacht die
Kräfte die bis jetzt in Russland
trainiert haben ausgebildet wurden jetzt
an die Front kommen
und die wird bis in sozusagen ihren
wahrscheinlich ihren Kulminationspunkt
im Frühling haben und dann gegen Sommer
über langsam wieder abflauen
dass wir das für die Ukraine eine Norm
harte Zeit weil viele Maßnahmen die im
Westen getroffen werden einfach für die
Abwehr dieser Offensive zu spät kommen
dass er nicht nur die kampfpanzerfrage
und die schützenpanzerfrage
sondern auch Steigerungen etwa der
munitionsproduktion die in den USA in
Schweden in Frankreich
veranlasst wurden im letzten Jahr aber
Industrie braucht immer eine Vorlaufzeit
man kann nicht einfach auf Knopfdruck
neue Fabriken bauen und Produktion
anschmeißen sondern die Maßnahmen die
damals im Sommer bzw im Herbst getroffen
wurden die haben Auswirkungen über das
Jahr hinaus und desto länger wie in
diesem Jahr sind desto besser wird die
Möglichkeit die Ukraine mit Munition zu
versorgen für diverse Waffentypen das
heißt aber auch dass wir jetzt noch in
einer sehr kritischen Phase knappe
Munitionsbestände für die Ukraine sind
und deshalb ist für die Ukraine dieser
Abwehrkampf enorm verlustreich und enorm
schwierig weil sie eben zurzeit
materiell in in keiner sehr guten
Verfassung ist
und das wird leider auch dazu führen
dass die Ukraine im Zuge dieser früher
als Offensive wahrscheinlich Gelände
verlieren wird das heißt Städte aufgeben
wird im Dom was wahrscheinlich etwas
zurückgeworfen wird was für die Ukraine
entscheidend ist ist jetzt
den Russen zu viel wie möglich an
Verlusten zuzufügen um eben diese
angriffsfähigkeit der russischen Armee
zu schwächen abzuschwächen damit man
dann im in der zweiten Hälfte des Jahres
wenn sich die materiellen logistischen
Voraussetzungen für die Ukraine deutlich
verbessert wieder eine bessere
Ausgangsposition hat dieses Gelände
wieder zurück zu gewinnen
eine Meldung die es heute auch noch gab
die wir über die wir unbedingt noch mal
sprechen sollten ist folgende für die
Ukraine spielt nämlich eigentlich von
Elon Musk da gibt es den Internetdienst
Darling kennen wahrscheinlich viele von
euch eine wichtige Rolle das sind
Satellitennetzwerk in der Ukraine hat er
eben Internetversorgung geliefert
sichergestellt wurde aber eben scheinbar
auch bei der Steuerung von Waffensystem
genutzt nun sagt SpaceX das ist also wo
Starling dazu gehört dass das nie dazu
gedacht gewesen sei als Waffe eingesetzt
zu werden das hat Darling erklärt was
bedeutet das denn jetzt für die Ukraine
wenn sie eben keinen Zugang mehr hätten
zu diesem Internet Netzwerk zu den
Satelliten zu Darling
das wäre für die ukrainische Chemie eine
ziemliche Katastrophe weil mit diesem
mobilen Internet das sehr gut
funktioniert das doch die Russen nicht
gestört werden kann
man immer eine eine Datenverbindung hat
damit kann man dann Geräte koppeln um
Materie anzufordern und Drohnen zu
betreiben
der Lage Informationen auszutauschen
selbst wenn man mit normalen Funkgeräten
nicht mehr durchkommt etwa durch
russische Störmaßnahmen elektronische
kampfführungsmaßnahmen bzw von der von
anderen Infrastruktur Teil komplett
abgeschnitten ist das Darling hat etwa
im eingekesselten mariopol bis zum
letzten Tag funktioniert das würde mit
landleitungen oder ähnlichen natürlich
nicht gehen deshalb ist das
Funktionieren von Starling für die
Ukraine enorm wichtig
die Ukraine haben dafür ja auch
diese Styling Geräte gekauft Zahlen auch
die Freiwilligen gibt es freiwillige
Einheiten die Spenden sammeln für für
diese stalinggeräte und
die Firma hat den Ukraine da einige
Ausnahmen von den normalen
Nutzungsbedingungen gestartet das hat
sie eigentlich im Frühjahr auch explizit
so gemacht etwas dass man eigentlich
statische Geräte in der Bewegung
einsetzt etc jetzt nachdem Elon Musk
immer tiefer in den russischen
Propaganda Sumpf eintauscht scheint es
hier Probleme zu geben dass diese
sonderausnahmen in den
Nutzungsbestimmungen jetzt wieder
zurückgenommen werden oder dass man
denkt die zurückzunehmen und somit
diesen diesen Geräten sozusagen die
Betreiber Lizenz zu entziehen und das
wäre natürlich für die Ukraine eine
enorm herberschlag vor allen Dingen da
sie auch da ist ja zurzeit keine
wirkliche Alternative zu diesem
darlingssystem gibt es gibt kaum andere
Anbieter die mit so vielen Satelliten in
so einem niedrigen Orbit
satellitentelefonie anbieten bzw
Satelliten Internet anbieten die diese
Übertragungs und diese Datenrate haben
wie wir das von staling kennen und da
ist jetzt leider die Ukraine jetzt
abhängig von einem sehr exzentrischen
Milliardär der glaubt er muss jetzt
Weltpolitik spielen
kommen wir aber jetzt Richtung Ende der
Sendung noch mal ganz kurz zurück zu
unserer Einbettung auch in die EU
anlässlich eben das EU-Gipfels warum wir
heute ja auch noch mal ganz gezielt auf
das Thema schauen dazu passt die Frage
von unserem sehr treuen User Sven
odental der Odenthal Entschuldigung der
glaube ich wirklich immer zu sieht er
fragte bei Facebook inwiefern herrschen
in der EU unterschiedliche Kriegsziele
und bedrohungsanalysen und inwiefern
können diese zur Belastung der
Zusammenarbeit in der EU und zur
Spaltung der NATO führen
es gibt sehr unterschiedliche also auf
der einen Extremposition ist natürlich
Umgang zu sehen
Victor Orban ein Putin Sympathisant auch
auch selber
ich sage mal so wenn es um
Geschichtsrevision um territuale
Revision geht jemand der sehr
ergebnisoffen lebt gestern gab es ja die
den Vorfall dass
slowakische Minister sagte wenn Russland
in Ukraine siegen würde würde Ungarn
theresiale Forderungen gegenüber der
Slowakei stellen das hat jetzt ein
bisschen dort für bilateralen Zank
gesorgt aber ich glaube
so weit weg ist diese slowakische
Einschätzung von der Realität nicht auf
der anderen Seite haben wir Polen die
baltischen Staaten die natürlich vor
allen Dingen aus dem eigenen
bedrohungsbewusstsein der Nachbarschaft
mit Russland jetzt natürlich hoffen dass
Russland diesen Krieg so bitte wie
möglich verliert damit das
Sicherheitsrisiko für sie singt und
diese diese
imperialen Ambitionen in Russland die
sich auch gegen sie richten können am
besten in der U eine in Rauch auflösen
also es gibt eine enorm große Bandbreite
bei der NATO ist das zurzeit unter
Anführungszeichen nicht zu tragisch weil
er die die Unterstützung für die Ukraine
wie gesagt rein bilateral auch wenn es
sozusagen innerhalb von NATO Gremien zum
Teil besprochen wird aber aber von der
Entscheidung her es kriegt bilateral
organisiert wird das heißt selbst wenn
man sich in Rammstein trifft sind es
immer bilaterale Zusagen Deutschlands
oder Polens oder Großbritannien etc
aber man bindet das nicht an gemeinsame
Entscheidungen bei der Europäischen
Union ist es ungleich schwieriger weil
hier etwa über Finanzrahmen über
eben Zahlungssysteme über tolle
Erleichterungen jetzt auch über über
Roaming Befreiungen etc überall das muss
immer der Rat abstimmen und
in wichtigen Fragen gilt natürlich im
Rat das Einstimmigkeitsprinzip und das
macht dann die Kompromissfindung enorm
schwierig weil dann eben Staaten wie
Ungarn ihr Veto einlegen
bzw
Orban das auch einfach nutzt um
Zugeständnisse anderer Art zu erpressen
und um Zugeständnisse an an Viktor Orban
sind sind selten eine sehr angenehme
Sache für für den Rest der Europäischen
Union
als letzte Frage zum Schluss unserer
Sendung weil es auch häufiger kam und
das stimmt auch na Jana wußmann schreibt
es geht nur noch um Waffenlieferungen
darüber reden wir in der Tat sehr oft
hier in unseren Sendung sie fragt sich
was ist mit friedensverhandlung es ist
realistisch überhaupt Herr kressel
aktuell darüber zu sprechen nachzudenken
was könnte dazu führen
zurzeit ist es leider relativ
unrealistisch also wir haben ein ein
Mitgrund warum man in der panzerfrage
unterstützenpanzerfrage vor allen Dingen
sie jetzt in Europa und in den USA über
diesen Winter ungeschwenkt ist ist ja
die die mangelnde
Verhandlungsbereitschaft Russland man
hat das mit verschiedenen
vorfühl Initiativen im November Dezember
gesehen will nicht verhandeln ersetzt
auf einen Krieg in der die in denen die
Ukraine so weitermattet bis sie
irgendwann keine militärischen
Widerstand mehr leisten kann keinen
organisierten um sie dann zu erobern
erstellt
neue Gebietsansprüche erstellt
Forderungen als Vorbedingungen für
Verhandlungen
die von denen er genau weiß die Ukraine
wird sie ablehnen damit er nicht
verhandeln muss das heißt zurzeit sind
wir leider in einer Situation wo Putin
auf Sieg setzt und wo Putin nicht
gewillt ist aus diesem Krieg in
irgendeiner anderen Form als einen Sieg
auszusteigen das kann sich natürlich
ändern dazu sind ja die
Waffenlieferungen da um genau das nicht
zuzulassen aber zurzeit sind wir halt
leider noch nicht dort vielleicht wenn
diese Frühjahrsoffensive scheitert und
sich dann die militärischen Optionen
Russlands erschöpfen wird sich das
ändern aber wie gesagt um dahin zu
kommen ist es noch ein weites langes
Stück Arbeit
ein Schätzung von Militärexperte Gustav
gressel auch Dank dafür aus unserer
Community User Rom schreibt danke für
klar verständlich die Fakten vermittelt
gut nachvollziehbar gerne öfter und mehr
als Gast das sei Ihnen an dieser Stelle
auch mitgegeben vielen Dank dass sie da
waren
viele
herzlichen Dank hat er noch gesagt und
auch euch vielen herzlichen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit es war eine lange Sendung
und deswegen ist jetzt auch Schluss und
gerne beim nächsten Mal wieder bis dahin
tschüss